Was ist das für ein Job,
wenn man als Essenskurier
für Uber Eats unterwegs ist?
Ist es so, wie die Firma sagt?
Kann man mit der Arbeit beginnen
und aufhören, wann man möchte?
Und kann man mit dieser Arbeit
genügend Geld zum Leben verdienen?
Das möchte ich wissen.
Und ich möchte Leute treffen,
die für Uber arbeiten.
* Rasante Musik *
Ich arbeite in der Stadt Zürich
ein paar Tage als Foodkurier.
Ich hole Essen im Restaurant ab
und bringe es den Leuten nach Hause.
So.
Der ganze Job läuft
über die Uber-App auf dem Handy.
Genau wie beim Taxi bricht Uber
nun auch bei den Essenskurieren
mit allem Dagewesenen.
Die Fahrer werden
von einem Algorithmus gesteuert.
Hoi.
- Sali.
Ich würde dich da drüben
gerne etwas fragen.
Ich treffe Kuriere, die Erfahrung
mit dieser Art von Arbeit haben,
z.B. Alex Höhn.
Es ist wie das Balancieren
auf einem Seil.
Es kann eine Flaute geben.
Manchmal gibt es
eine halbe Stunde keine Lieferung.
Manchmal prasseln die Bestellungen
nur so rein - es ist unvorhersehbar.
Das System ist sehr willkürlich.
Was das am Ende
für einen Lohn geben kann,
möchte dieser Fahrer aus Südafrika
vor der Kamera nur anonym erzählen.
Wenn ich das ausrechne,
komme ich auf 10-11 Fr. pro Stunde.
Das ist vielleicht in Südafrika viel
Geld, aber nicht hier in Zürich.
So habe ich mich ursprünglich
für diesen Job angemeldet.
Verdeckt als Journalistin
der Konsumentensendung "Kassensturz"
des Schweizer Fernsehens.
"Kein Vorgesetzter. Flexibler
Zeitplan. Schnelle Auszahlungen."
Das klingt super.
Die Anmeldung geht extrem schnell,
ist bestechend einfach
und läuft von Anfang an
über eine App.
"Lieferung per Fahrrad".
Was, wie, wann kann ich bestimmen.
Wir nehmen 11 Uhr.
Montag, der 25., um 11 Uhr.
Sogar der Termin,
um mich vorzustellen.
Ich habe gleich mein
Vorstellungsgespräch bei Uber Eats.
Dann kommt aus, ob ich
Kurierfahrer werde oder nicht.
Es ist an der Badenerstrasse 565,
hinter dem Letzigrund.
Ich muss nichts mitnehmen,
bloss meine ID und, wenn vorhanden,
einen Auszug aus dem Strafregister.
Mal schauen, was da passiert.
In Zürich findet man Uber Eats
weder im Telefonbuch
noch hat die Firma
eine Telefonnummer.
Wer von Uber etwas will,
muss in dieses Büro kommen.
Alles wirkt total unverbindlich.
Es ist dann auch
kein Vorstellungsgespräch,
sondern eine sog. Infosession.
Während einer halben Stunde erklärt
mir eine junge Frau die Firmen-App.
Sie zeigt mir,
in welchem Gebiet ich arbeite
und was ich
pro Lieferung verdienen kann -
inkl. verschiedene Boni
wie z.B. ein Regenbonus.
Zu meiner Person
will die Frau nichts wissen.
Einzig ein Selfie für mein Profilbild
muss ich machen.
Der Strafregisterauszug
interessiert sie nicht.
Nach der Infosession
kann ich mit der Arbeit beginnen
und habe schon Schulden
bei Uber Eats.
Für 120 Fr. habe ich
einen Kurierrucksack gekauft,
den ich mit den ersten Fahrten
abzahlen muss.
Das Gespräch ist vorbei.
Das Wichtigste ist,
dass ich selbstständig bin -
eine selbstständige Partnerin
von Uber.
Sie hat mir die App erklärt.
Ich habe nach
einer Unfallversicherung gefragt.
Wenn mir etwas passiere,
würde sie mir einen Bonus geben,
ich müsse aber selbst
unfallversichert sein.
Doch das ist
der grosse Haken an diesem Job.
Die Suva, die Unfallversicherung,
wird mich nicht aufnehmen.
Sie sagt, Uber-Eats-Fahrer
erfüllen die Bedingungen
für selbstständig Erwerbende nicht.
Dazu kommen wir später noch.
Ich muss nun
meinen Essensrucksack vorbereiten.
Übrigens: Anstatt in abzuzahlen,
könne ich ihn auch
innerhalb eines Monats zurückgeben
und mir einen anderen besorgen,
egal, ob angeschrieben oder nicht,
sagt Uber.
So.
Unterwegs bin ich
mit meinem Kameramann,
der mich in meinen ersten paar
Stunden als Uber-Fahrerin begleitet.
Es ist Nachmittag, 14 Uhr,
und ich gehe das erste Mal
auf der App online.
Nach 20 Min.
bekomme ich den ersten Auftrag.
Bis zum Restaurant
verdiene ich noch nichts.
Der Anfahrtsweg sei aber nie mehr als
1-3 km, sagte mir die Frau von Uber.
Bei mir wird das
praktisch nie stimmen.
Oh, schau, hier.
Hallo.
- (Frau) Hallo.
Hast du Essen bestellt?
- Ja, hallo. - Hoi.
Ich hoffe, es ist noch warm.
Es war eine lange Reise.
Vielen Dank.
- Gern geschehen.
Guten Appetit.
- Einen schönen Tag noch. - Tschüss.
"Geliefert".
Nach gut 1 Std. habe ich mit meinem
ersten Auftrag 12.14 Fr. verdient.
Brutto.
Ich bin ziemlich gefordert
und habe keinen Handy-Akku mehr.
Auch das hat mir die Frau bei Uber
an der Infosession gesagt.
Sie empfehle mir,
eine Power Bank zu kaufen.
Ich habe mir im Geschäft eine geholt.
Sogleich folgt der nächste Auftrag.
"11 Min., 4,6 km".
Deutlich mehr als die versprochenen
1-3 km unbezahlter Anfahrtsweg.
Gesetzlich bin ich mit jeder Fahrt
in einem Graubereich unterwegs.
Uber-Eats-Fahrer gelten in der
Schweiz als Schein-Selbstständige.
Sie sind unversichert
und können keine AHV abrechnen.
Diverse Gerichtsverfahren
sind hängig, weil sich Uber weigert,
die Fahrer anzustellen.
Bis entschieden ist, was gilt,
kann es noch Jahre dauern.
Solange es
kein rechtsgültiges Urteil gibt,
kontrollieren in Zürich die Behörden
weder Lohn noch Arbeitsbedingungen
von Uber-Eats-Fahrern.
Uber ist ein börsenkotiertes
multinationales Unternehmen
aus Kalifornien, das jährlich
Milliardenumsätze macht.
Die Logik
solcher Plattformunternehmen:
binnen Kürze alle anderen verdrängen.
Eines der Mittel: massive Werbung.
Uber Eats ist z.B. neu Namenssponsor
der französischen Fussball-Ligue-1
und zahlt dafür
pro Jahr 15 Mio. Euro.
Ab der neuen Saison
sollen Foodkuriere den Spielball
aufs Feld der Millionäre bringen.
Ziemlich zynisch, diese Idee.
(TV-Sprecher) Franck avait 19 ans
et la vie devant lui.
In Frankreich
starb 2019 ein junger Foodkurier
während einer Fahrt für Uber Eats.
Es ist nicht der erste tödliche
Unfall eines Uber-Eats-Kuriers.
Er wurde
von einem Lastwagen überfahren.
In Bordeaux wurde für ihn
demonstriert und gleichzeitig
das Geschäftsmodell
von Uber Eats kritisiert,
Risiken
einseitig auf die Kuriere abzuwälzen.
Schon nach einigen Fahrten in Zürich
ist mir klar,
wie gefährlich
der Job als Velokurier ist.
Viel Verkehr
und man ist ständig am Handy,
um zu schauen, wohin man fahren muss,
und um keinen Auftrag zu verpassen.
Wegen der Sicherheit
hat sich der Kurier Alex Höhn
z.B. gerade kürzlich
eine Handyhalterung gekauft.
Es ist sehr gefährlich.
Auch so ist es gefährlich.
Man muss so aufmerksam fahren
auf diesen Strassen.
Wenn man wegschaut,
kann alles passieren.
Ich möchte mich nicht verletzen.
Es geht mir nicht mal um die Regeln.
Ich möchte keinen Unfall bauen.
Passanten haben teils Kopfhörer auf.
Manchmal ein Wunder,
dass sie nicht angefahren werden.
Ich konzentriere mich auf
den Strassenverkehr. Dann geht es.
Als Velofahrer, speziell als Kurier,
muss man etwas vorausschauen.
Etwas vorausdenken,
damit nichts passiert.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Uber hat mich nie
in einem persönlichen Gespräch
über die Risiken informiert.
Da steht nichts
in irgendeinem Vertrag.
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
wer zahlt, wenn mir etwas passiert.
Ich weiss nicht mal, was passiert,
wenn jemand mein Velo klaut,
während ich einem Kunden
eine Lieferung bringe.
Du hast nichts.
- Ich habe nichts.
Ich weiss nicht,
zu wem ich gehen soll.
Ich habe nichts von Uber.
Ich weiss nicht mal,
wer für Uber in Oerlikon
oder in Zürich zuständig ist.
Oder in der Schweiz.
Ich weiss es nicht.
Die Konsumentensendung "Kassensturz"
des Schweizer Fernsehens
hat Uber Eats mit
dem Vorwurf konfrontiert,
sie vernachlässigen
die Sicherheit der Fahrer.
Die Sprecherin hat dann gesagt:
Wir versuchen, im Rahmen
des aktuell Möglichen als Plattform,
unseren Kunden,
das sind Fahrer und Kuriere,
so viel wie möglich anzubieten,
um sie abzusichern.
Ja, wir würden
auch gerne noch mehr machen.
Dazu sind wir absolut bereit.
Tatsächlich ist es aber so,
dass man in der heutigen Situation
entweder
als Arbeitgeber eingestuft wird,
was dann mit
dem Flexibilitätsverlust einhergeht
für diejenigen,
die Arbeitnehmer werden.
Sie möchten also auf keinen Fall
als Arbeitgeber eingestuft werden.
Das haben Sie soeben gesagt.
Das können wir uns
aktuell nicht vorstellen.
Unter den Voraussetzungen,
wie Arbeitgeber
heute in der Schweiz definiert sind,
kann man nicht die Flexibilität
eines Selbstständigen gewährleisten.
Das höchste Gut
in der digitalisierten Arbeitswelt:
Flexibilität.
Uber weigert sich, die Verantwortung
des Arbeitgebers zu übernehmen
und überlässt die Risiken und Kosten
den Fahrern und der Allgemeinheit.
Ich merke selbst,
wie man als Fahrer alleine ist
am Beispiel eines total
banalen Alltagsproblems wie hier.
* Rattern am Fahrrad *
Ah, Scheisse.
Mein Rücklicht hat sich gelöst.
Es hängt in die Speichen rein.
So kann ich nicht mehr fahren.
Ich sollte einen Auftrag liefern.
Ich versuche,
es provisorisch zu reparieren,
damit es nicht mehr ins Rad hängt.
Mit ziemlicher Verspätung
komme ich zum Restaurant.
So. Ich hatte technische Probleme.
Die Pechsträhne geht weiter.
Hallo. Habt ihr was?
(Frau) Wir haben es schon
einzeln geschickt.
Einzeln? Was heisst das?
Jemand anderem?
Sie hat eine vegane Curry Bowl
und Himbeer...
Wir haben es schon geschickt.
- Mit Uber Eats? - Ja.
Vor 5 Min.
- Ich rufe den Support an.
Sehr gerne. Danke.
Ich warte 10 Min. in einer
Warteschlaufe, niemand geht ran.
Als sie mir die App erklärt hat,
sagte sie,
bei einem Problem
soll ich diese Nummer anrufen.
Ich fragte sie, ob ich dann bei ihr
lande, an der Badenerstrasse 565.
Da sagte sie: "Nein.
Im Supportcenter in Portugal."
In Portugal
hat offenbar niemand Zeit.
Tja.
Ich weiss nicht, was ich tun soll.
In diesem Moment denke ich,
das sei alles wegen meiner Velopanne.
Weil ich deutlich zu spät
unterwegs war,
hätte der Algorithmus
einen anderen Fahrer aufgeboten,
um mich zu ersetzen.
Das Restaurant ist auch verwirrt
und bereitet nochmals ein Essen vor,
weil sie tatsächlich zwei praktisch
identische Bestellungen haben.
"Lieferung beginnen".
"20 Min., 4 km".
Gut. Gehen wir.
Kreuz und quer durch die Stadt.
Gedanklich absorbiert,
was das alles soll, versuche ich,
mich wieder
auf den Verkehr zu konzentrieren.
Hallo.
Sorry für das Durcheinander.
Vor 30 Min. ist jemand gekommen
und hat es gebracht.
Du hast das Essen erhalten?
- Ja.
Hä?
- Ich nehme es schon.
Ich liege im Bett mit Denguefieber.
Du bist kr... Denguefieber?
Nein! Ist das ansteckend?
- Nein.
Ehrlich? Denguefieber?
Ist das eine Mücke?
Ja.
Warst du in Afrika?
- Thailand.
Und du hast das erste Mal
Essen bei Uber bestellt? - Ja.
Und jetzt kriegst du zwei Essen.
- Das ist doch gut für mich.
Ich habe keine Kraft, rauszugehen.
- Okay.
Was wir beide in diesem Moment nicht
wissen und sich erst später klärt:
Ihr Essen hat Manuela Haltinner
auf der Uber-Onlineplattform
zweimal bestellt - ungewollt.
Ich hatte 1 Std. und bekomme 11 Fr.
für eine Lieferung.
Du weisst nicht im Voraus,
wie viel du verdienst?
Nein, keine Ahnung.
Man hat dauernd ...
Schau! Es sucht Fahrten für mich.
Die nächste Lieferung, während
ich mit dir spreche. Ich nehme sie.
Ah, du siehst, wo du hinmusst.
Das ist in der Nähe.
Das ist nah, ja. 6 Min., La Casa.
Das ist super.
Der erste nahe Auftrag.
Vielleicht komme ich heute
noch zu einem guten Verdienst.
Vielen Dank.
- Schönen Abend.
Wünsche ich dir auch.
Tschüss, Manuela.
Tschüss zusammen.
- Tschüss.
Es bleibt Wunschdenken.
Am Ende komme ich auf einen Lohn
von rund 10 Fr. brutto pro Stunde.
Ein Dumpinglohn,
von dem man nicht leben kann.
Ich möchte wissen,
warum Fahrer diese Arbeit machen.
Alex Höhn,
der pausenlos Aufträge annimmt,
extrem sportlich fährt und nur zu
besten Lieferzeiten unterwegs ist,
verdient im Schnitt 20 Fr. brutto.
Ich hatte Bock, das zu machen. Ich
wollte das schon vor Jahren machen.
Velokurier sein?
- Ja. Ich fahre gerne Velo.
Aber es ist nicht
meine Haupteinnahmequelle.
Als Hauptberuf
würde ich es nicht machen.
Dann wäre es viel ...
Dann wäre es zu wenig.
Mein Ziel ist es, irgendwo
als Fahrer fest angestellt zu sein.
Jetzt probiere ich nur aus,
wie der Job so ist -
bevor ich zu notime oder Veloblitz
wechsle, wenn es möglich ist.
Du machst es also,
weil du nichts anderes hast.
Ich habe nichts anderes.
Ich mache es, weil ich Geld brauche.
Ich bin Ausländer, ich brauche Geld,
um meine Familie zu ernähren.
Deshalb mache ich das -
nur für das Geld.
Ich sehe in diesem Job
keine Zukunft für mich.
Aber für den Moment mache ich es,
um weiterzukommen
und zumindest etwas zu essen
auf dem Tisch zu haben.
Ajoub kommt aus Spanien
und will hier Fuss fassen.
Er hat die Aufenthaltsbewilligung L.
Mein Bruder hat mir gesagt,
ich soll es versuchen, es sei gut.
Warum?
Weil ich nichts anderes habe.
Ich habe keine andere Arbeit.
Im "Kassensturz"
hat die Sprecherin von Uber Eats
zum tiefen Lohn gesagt:
Hätte Ihre Kollegin
sich vielleicht dazu entschieden,
am Nachmittag oder am Abend
Essen auszuliefern,
wäre sie sicherlich besser gefahren.
Sie hat mit anderen gesprochen, die
auch nur auf 10 Fr. gekommen sind.
Und das reicht nicht aus.
Der zweite Faktor, der dazu
beiträgt, wie viel man verdient,
ist, wie viele Aufträge man annimmt.
Auch da hat Ihre Kollegin
nur die Hälfte angenommen.
Wenn man sich anschaut,
wie viel die Kuriere im Durchschnitt
während den Essenszeiten
verdienen ...
Sozusagen in der Rushhour.
Dann sind das im Schnitt 21 Fr.
- Genau.
Wenn jemand also
länger arbeiten will,
trägt er ein grosses Risiko,
dass er wenig verdient.
Das ist ein Risiko,
das Sie an die Menschen auslagern.
Das ist genau der Grund, warum sich
Kuriere dafür entscheiden,
mit Uber Eats tätig zu sein:
Sie suchen
keine Ganztagsbeschäftigung,
sondern einen flexiblen Nebenerwerb.
Für 11 Std.?
Ich treffe verschiedene Fahrer,
die es nicht als Nebenerwerb,
sondern als Hauptjob machen, z.B.
dieser Mann, der anonym bleiben will.
Wie viel arbeitest du pro Tag?
10 oder 11 Std.
- 10 Std.? 11 Std.?
Und du verdienst etwa 200 Fr.?
- Ja.
Er hat also einen Brutto-Stundenlohn
von 18 Fr.,
das Motorrad noch nicht abgezogen.
Mich dünkt, viele Fahrer
sind sich nicht der Risiken bewusst,
die man mit dieser Arbeit
auf sich nimmt.
Es wirkt verlockend,
zu arbeiten, wann man möchte.
Aber der Preis dafür ist hoch.
Es ist ein moderner Job, bei dem der
eigentliche Chef ein Algorithmus ist.
Es profitieren
die Plattform und die Kunden
auf Kosten derjenigen, die auf
der Strasse für sie unterwegs sind.
Ich möchte wissen, was ihr schon
mit Uber Eats erlebt habt -
sei es als Kunde oder als Fahrer.
Schreibt mir eure Meinung.
Wenn ihr weiterhin über alle
SRF-DOK-Filme informiert sein wollt,
abonniert diesen Kanal.